hi in this video we discuss what design
of experiments or short doe is what the
process steps of a doe project are how a
doe can help you reduce the number of
experiments how to estimate the number
of experiments needed and we go through
the most common types of design finally
I'll show you how to create a doe online
with data tab let's start with the first
question what is design of experiments
design of experiments is a systematic
approach to planning conducting and
analyzing
experiments but what is the aim of
design of experiments the aim is to
analyze the relationship between several
input variables and an output variable
the input variables of the system are
called factors and the output variable
is called response variable of course
there can also be several response
variables therefore factors are the
variable believe to affect the response
each factor now has at least two levels
these levels are the specific values a
factor can take and we want to find out
whether a change in the levels of the
factors has an influence on the response
let's look at an example when you paddle
a bike the wheels rotate around a
central Rod known as the axle to ensure
that the wheel can spin there are
bearings now now imagine you're paddling
your bike on a smooth road if the
bearings are in good condition the
wheels will spin easily the so-called
frictional torque in this case is low if
the bearing is in not a good condition
you have to push harder to keep the same
speed because there's more frictional
torque now we want to investigate what
influences the frictional torque of a
bearing using a doe in this case
frictional torque is obviously our
response variable possible factors could
be lubrication or temperature
lubrication could have the levels oil
and greased and temperature could have
the levels low medium and high now we
want to know what influen the different
levels have on the response variable due
is now helping us to create an efficient
test plan to determine this influence
especially if we have not only two
variables but several this can result in
great savings for sure depending on the
field of study the system under
investigation can be a process a machine
or a product but of course also humans
for example if you want to investigate
the influence of medication but what are
the two main areas of application of
design of experiments either you want to
identify relevant factors I.E you want
to know which factors have a significant
influence on the response variable or
you want to find the optimal input
variable in other words you want to find
the input variables that optimize the
response variable of course both steps
can also be carried out one after the
other so let's take a look at the
process of a doe project planning
screening optimization and verification
in the first step planning three things
are important first to gain clear
understanding of the problem and the
system second to determine one or more
response variables third identify
factors that can significantly influence
the response variable the task of
determining potential factors that
influence the response variable can be
very complex and timec consuming for
example a fishbone diagram can be
created in a team now comes the Second
Step the screening if there are many
factors that could have an influence
usually more than four to six factors
screening experiments should be carried
out to reduce the number of factors why
is this important the number of factors
to be investigated has a major influence
on the number of experiments required
note in design of experiments the
individual experiments are also simply
called runs in the full factorial design
which we will discuss in more detail in
a moment the number of experiments or
runs is n equal to 2 to the power of K
where n is the number of runs and K is
the number of factors here is a small
overview if we have three factors for
example we have to make at least eight
runs with seven factors it is already at
least 128 runs and with 10 factors it is
already at least
1,24 runs please note that this table
applies to a doe where each factor only
has two levels otherwise there will be
even more runs depending on how complex
an individual experiment is it may
therefore be worthwhile to select
so-called screening designs for four or
more factors later we will discuss the
fractional factorial design and the
black at Burman design which can be used
for screening experiments once the
significant factors have been identified
using screening designs and hopefully
the number of factors has been reduced
further experiments can now be conducted
the data obtained can then be used to
create a regression model which helps to
determine the input variables in such a
way that the response variable is
optimized after optimization comes the
final step verification this involves
checking once again whether the
calculated optimal input variables
really have the desired influence on the
response variable depending on whether
we are in the the screening step or the
optimization step there are different
types of design the best known are full
factorial design fractional factorial
design blacket Burman design box banking
design Central composite design of
course you can create all these types of
designs online at data.net let's first
take a look at the full factorial and
the fractional factorial design we can
then also answer the question why all
the effort why design of experiments and
what do we need statistics for
experiments cost time and money the
number of runs should therefore be kept
as small as possible but beware if the
number of runs is too small there is a
high risk that relevant differences will
not be recognized let's take a look at
an example we would like to investigate
which factors have an influence on the
frictional torque of a bearing let's
start with one factor lubrication we
would like to know whether it has an
influence on the frictional torque if a
bearing is oiled or greased to find out
we take a random sample of 10 bearings
we oil one half of the bearings and
grease the other half now we can measure
the frictional torque of the five oil
bearings and the five grease bearings
but stop y 10 bearings in most cases
each run costs a lot of money perhaps we
can manage with fewer runs so how many
experiments do we need in order to find
out if the lubricant has an effect on a
frictional torque let's just start with
the 10 bearings we can now calculate the
mean value of the frictional torque of
the oil and greased bearings then we can
calculate the difference between the two
mean values in this sample we can see
that there is a difference between oiled
and greased however we can already see
that the frictional torque in the oil
oiled and greased bearings is highly
scattered if we take another random
sample of 10 bearings it is possible
that this time the difference will be
greater but it is also possible that the
difference will be in exactly the
opposite direction in another words the
frictional torque of the bearings
scatters The Wider the spread the more
difficult it is to identify a specific
difference or effect fortunately the
variability of the mean value can be
reduced by increasing the sample size
the larger the sample size the more
precise is the estimation of the mean
therefore the smaller the effect and The
Wider the spread of the response
variable the larger the sample needs to
be but how much larger how can you
estimate the number of runs needed you
can use this formula as an approximation
here n is the number of runs Sigma is
the standard deviation and Delta is the
f back to be determined for example if
we have a standard deviation of 3 Newt
mm and a difference of 5 Newton mm is
relevant for us then we need 22 runs if
we only have a standard deviation of 2
Newt mm we only need 10 runs and with a
standard deviation of 1 Newton mm we get
2.4 so we need two runs with greased
bearings and two runs with oiled
bearings but how can du help you reduce
the number of runs let's assume that the
calculation of the number of runs
results in 16 experiments so eight runs
with oil bearings and eight runs with
greased bearings but what if we have a
second Factor let's say in addition to
lubrication we have temperature with low
and high then we need another eight runs
to take these factors into account so we
need 16 runs to check if the lubricant
has an effect and it's 16 runs to check
if the temperature has an effect this
gives us a total of 24 runs now the
question arises is it possible to
achieve this with fewer runs and that
brings us to the full factorial design
the question is why should we limit
ourselves to testing one factor at a
time instead we could device a design
that incorporates the false potential
combination which is grease and high
temperature of course we still need 16
runs per Factor we get this by making
four runs with each of the four
combinations then we have eight runs
with oil and eight with grease and on
the other side eight with low
temperature and eight with high
temperature we now have a total of 16
runs before that we had 24 runs we now
need fewer experiments and get even more
information why more information we now
also know whether there is an
interaction between temperature and luri
ration for example oil bearings may show
A variation in frictional torque at
different temperatures which is not
observed with greased bearings this
information would have been lost
previously now when we have three
factors instead of two the savings are
even higher if we test one of the three
factors at a time we need 32 runs if we
now run two experiments for each
combination in a full factorial design
we still only need 60 runs however for
each factor we still have eight runs per
Factor level for example for the
lubrication Factor we have eight runs
with oil and eight runs with grease of
course we can also create full factorial
designs with more than two levels for
example the temperature Factor could
have three Factor levels low medium and
high however as mentioned at the
beginning even with a full factorial
design with two levels in each factor
the number of runs required increases
very quickly as the number of factors
increases let us therefore now take a
look at the fractional factorial design
the fractional factorial design is used
for screening designs I.E if you have
more than approximately four to six
factors of course reducing the number of
runs means reducing information in
fractional factorial designs the
resolution is reduced what is the
resolution the resolution is is a
measure of how well a doe can
distinguish between different effects
more precisely the resolution indicates
how much the main effects and
interaction effects are confounded in a
design but what are main effects and
interaction effects and what does
confounded mean in design of experiments
the term effect refers to the impact
that a certain factor or a combination
of factors has on the response variable
of an experiment essentially they
measure how much the response variable
changes when you change the factors a
main effect is now the influence of a
single Factor on the response variable
for example what influence the
lubrication of a bearing has on the
frictional torque interaction effects
occur when the effect of one factor on
the response variable depends on the
level of another factor for example the
effect of the lubricant on the
frictional torque could depend on the
temperature but what does that mean
let's say we have an average frictional
torque value of 102 new mm for the
bearings with oil and an average value
of 108 Newton mm for the bearings with
grease then we have a main effec of
lubrication of 6 Newton mm but now we
can break this down into high and low
temperatures at high temperature we
could get 98 for oil and 102 for grease
so that the difference between oil and
grease is only 4 Newton mm at low
temperature we could get 104 and2 so a
difference of eight so the lubrication
factor is influenced by the temperature
and we have an interaction between
lubrication and temperature the
interaction leads to a difference of 2
Newton mm to the original result we
therefore have an interaction effect of
2 new mm full factorial designs take all
interactions into account in our bearing
friction example in addition to the
lubricant and temperature factors we
also looked at the interaction between
lubricant and temperature however as the
number of factors increases numberous
interactions rapidly emerge for example
if we have the five factors a b c d and
e we get the interaction between two
factors between three factors between
four factors and between all five
factors
now of course the question is do we
really need all the interactions or can
we reduce the resolution and this is
exactly what the fractional factorial
design does in a fractional factorial
design interactions can be confounded
with other interactions or with main
effects or factors what does confounded
mean effects of different factors or the
effect of interaction of factors cannot
be separated from each other the extent
to which the number of runs can be
reduced at the expense of resolution is
shown in this table the resolution is
usually indicated by Roman nums EG 3 4 5
and so on and so forth here on the
diagonal we see the full factorial
designs we'll go through what
resolutions three four and five mean in
a moment for example if we have six
factors we need at least 64 runs for a
full factorial design if we choose a
fraction factorial design with a
resolution of six we need 32 runs with a
resolution of four we need 16 runs and
with a resolution of three we need only
eight runs but what does that mean and
how does it work the full factorial
design is always used as the starting
point let's take a look at the example
with eight runs let's say we have the
factors a b and c with a full factorial
design we can now test whether factor a
b or C have an effect we can test
whether the interactions with two
factors have an effect and whether the
interaction with all three factors has
an effect if we now want to test not
just three factors with eight runs but
an additional fourth Factor say Factor D
then we must drop the information from
one of the interactions for example the
interaction of a b and c if we want to
test a fifth factor with a trials let's
say Factor e then we will have to drop
another interaction for example the
interaction between B and C but I didn't
express myself correctly we are not
actually dropping the information we are
mixing the new factor with the
interaction we've confounded the factor
with the interaction what does that mean
it means that we are unable to determine
if an observed effect is attributable to
factor D or to the interaction of a b
and c similarily we can't distinguish if
an effect results from Factor e or from
the interaction of A and B of course it
is much less critical to mix one factor
with an interaction of three factors
than with an interaction of two factors
and now we have a good transition to the
resolution what do the resolutions 3
four and five mean at resolution three
main effects can be confounded with
interactions of two factors for example
Factor D with the interaction of the
factors A and B experiments with
resolution three should therefore be
considered as critical they can only be
used if the interaction of two factors
is significantly smaller than the
effects of the main factors otherwise
the interaction of two factors can
significantly distort the result of one
factor experiments at resolution 4 are
much less critical here only the main
effects are confounded with the
interactions of the three factors and
the more factors are involved in an
interaction the smaller the effect is
likely to be furthermore in resolution
four interactions with two factors are
confounded with interactions with other
two factors experiments at resolution
five are not considered critical main
effects are only confounded with
interactions of four factors in the same
way two Factor interactions are only
only confounded with interactions of
three factors but how do you confound a
factor and an interaction let's take a
look at this example here we have the
full factorial design of the three
factors a b and c these eight runs are
carried out in total we still only
consider factors with two levels minus
one stands for one level and one for the
other for our frictional torque example
the test plan would then look like this
for example for the factor temperature
minus one is the low temperature and one
is the high temperature if we now run
the experiments we obtain a value for
the response variable for each run if
the factor a is one or minus one this
has a certain effect on the target value
exactly the same if the factor B is one
or minus one the interaction effect now
tells us whether there is an additional
effect if Factor A and B are
simultaneously one or minus one or if
both go in exactly opposite direction so
on one side we have the pairings with
the same sign and on the other side the
pairings with an unequal sign now we can
check whether there is a difference in
the response variable between the values
in the green group and the values in the
red group if yes then there is an
interaction between A and B however if
we know in advance that there is only a
very small all interaction if any then
we can use these combinations to test a
fourth Factor D to do this we simply
multiply A and B now we always have a
one if the factors A and B have the same
sign and minus one if they have a
different sign now of course a problem
may arise when analyzing the results if
there is a difference between the green
and the red values in the response
variable we cannot say whether this
effect comes from the interaction
between a and b or whether the effect
comes from the factor D if we are
already sure that there can be no
interaction between A and B this is of
course not a problem then we can be sure
that the difference is due to factor D
in the same way we can now take the
interaction of a and c and also measure
Factor e and the interaction of A and B
and C and measure factor F therefore in
this case we measure six factors with
only eight runs but we can no longer
distinguish the factor D from the
interaction A and B we can no longer
distinguish the factor E from the
interaction A and C and we can no longer
distinguish factor F from the
interaction a b and c and now let's take
a quick look at the other types of
designs and then I'll show you how you
can create a doe online with data tab
black at Burman designs Black at Burman
designs are usually designed with two
levels and with resolution three the
main advantage of blacket Burman designs
is that the interaction of two factors
is distributed over several factors for
example the interaction a b is
confounded with all factors except with
the factors A and B this makes black and
Burman designs particularly suitable
when there are many factors and only the
main effects are of interest but beware
blacket Burman designs should only be
used if it can be assume that we can
neglect two Factor interactions however
this requirement is not quite as strict
as for classical fractional factorial
designs of resolutions 3 let's move on
to the last two designs the central
composite design and the Box banking
design aim to analyze and optimize a few
factors in more detail and can identify
nonlinear dependencies to determine
nonlinear dependencies at least three
levels per Factor are required with a
full factorial design with three levels
however the number of Trials increases
very quickly with two factors with three
levels each we need nine runs with three
factors with three levels each we
already need 27 runs the number of
attempts increases with three times the
number of factors this is where the Box
banking design comes into play a full
factorial design is created with two
levels in each case further the center
point is included in the design for
example three times for example with two
factors we have the full factorial
design with two levels plus the center
point as well as with three factors this
greatly reduces the number of fronts in
this case from 27 to 15 nevertheless
less nonlinear relationships can be
determined let's move on to the last
design the central composite design a
central composite design typically
consist of three different types of test
points two level full factorial points
these form the corner points of a cube
or a hyper cube in multi-dimensional
spaces Central points they lie in the
center of the space defined by the
factorial points axal points these on
the axis of the factor space outside the
cube the last two points help to
estimate the nonlinear effects and now I
show you how you can create your doe
online with data tab to do this simply
go to data.net click on plus and then on
doe here you can select which design
type you would like to create it a full
factorial design or a fractional
factorial design next you can select the
number of factors and make specific
settings for the respective designs for
the fractional factorial design for
example you can specify the number of
factors and the number of fronts you can
now enter the names of the factors and
the values for the levels for example
temperature with low and
high and lubrication with oil and
grease here you can see the experiments
each row is one run or one
experiment further you can export the
table to excel now you can carry out the
experiments after you have performed the
tests you can copy all the data back to
data Tab and evaluate the results but
more on that in the next video I hope
you enjoyed this video and I'll see you
again
soon